that Sam hunt being released from jail
on Thursday morning et has learned the
country crooner was arrested for driving
under the influence following a night
out with friends at the Ainsworth Bar in
Nashville drinking too much drinking too
much
the drinkin too much singer was
allegedly traveling on the wrong side of
a street in Nashville when police
noticed and pulled him over and the
arrest report alleges there was an
obvious odor consistent with alcoholic
beverage coming from Sam as well as red
bloodshot and watery eyes and according
to police Hunt's blood-alcohol level was
point one seven three more than twice
the legal limit Sam was booked around
6:30 a.m. local time but posted a $2,500
bond and was released less than three
hours later no word on whether Sam's
wife Hannah was in town during the
incident the pair Wed just over two
years ago
sharing life in a more intimate way with
somebody she doesn't put me on a
pedestal and that backed rate whatever
that is her ability to just to see
through the thing and deer's me to her
yeah Sam's been largely focused on his
marriage and has kept a lower profile
over the past few years it's been five
years since he dropped his hugely
successful debut album do you feel
pressure because that was so successful
yeah I feel that pressure but I just
when I had those songs ready for my
Novello I had such a certainty about
putting those songs on the record and
putting those out to the world and those
that's what I wanted to say at that time
and since then I just haven't had that
confirmation of that conviction about
anything that I've worked on so far so
you're waiting for that
yeah there's such an expectation because
you know most artists put out records
over a couple years and I'm just not
maybe as prolific a writer as somebody
said Sam is scheduled to appear in court
on January 17 2020 he has reached out
for comment
[Music]